suicide it's the second leading cause of
death for teens and young adults in our
state that's according to the American
Foundation For Suicide Prevention today
Coronado High School's hope Squad hosted
its rainbow run to combat suicide and
promote mental health Lauren negretti
takes us there and shows us teens
helping teens
[Applause]
running for mental health and suicide
prevention a big mission for Coronado
High School's hope Squad we have found
with hope Squad that the more that we
have an open dialogue about talking
about suicide prevention and awareness
the more that people realize it's okay
to ask for help theirs and other schools
Unite with Community stakeholders and
Social Service organizations to spread
positive messages Coronado sophomore
Michelle Park I've personally struggled
with depression sometimes anxiety
throughout the past years and I think
that honestly it happens to everybody
especially when you're in high school
and like you know it can get really
stressful in your teen years and
everything so I think it's just really
I'm really glad that we were doing this
hope squads Are Meant To Train student
mentors to serve as safe and trusted
peers to talk to a task park has taken
on before it's really important that
we're going out and helping each other
when we can and I'm just I have done it
a few times and I'm just glad that
sometimes I can do something to make
another person feel a little better
various speakers talked about the need
to address mental health one
organization investing in the local hope
Squad
Intermountain Health donating to support
existing hope squads their programming
and New Hope squats we want to help them
succeed and to prevent as many suicides
as possible that started
Club member of two years she's struggled
with mental health herself I have taken
steps in my own life to seek therapy and
things like that but I don't think I
would have gotten there without like
meeting the people that I met through
hope Squad and all of the resources
there
now if you or someone you know needs
help you can call the National Suicide
and crisis Lifeline at 988